i chose wakanda
our future depends you are wrong
all of you are wrong
to turn your backs on the rest of the
world
we let the fear of our discovery stop us
from doing what is right
no more
welcome to your weekly ticket
this is normally where we start weekly
ticket with a news roundup but today
our hearts are with chadwick boseman's
family friends
fans and collaborators the black panther
actor passed away after a four-year
battle with colon cancer
his representatives confirmed the news
friday evening saying he spent the last
four years working as an actor
while simultaneously battling the
illness bozeman worked on 10 films over
the course of those years including
captain america civil war
black panther and defy bloods while he
was best known for his character
t'challa in the mcu he also played
several real-life black heroes
including jackie robinson thoroughgood
marshall and james brown
his fans and co-stars quickly took to
social media with tributes for the late
star
black panther director ryan coogler
penned a letter writing in part
it is with a heavy heart and a sense of
deep gratitude to have ever been in his
presence that i have to reckon with the
fact that
chad is an ancestor now and former
captain america star chris evans wrote
i am absolutely devastated this is
beyond heartbreaking
chadwick was special a true original he
was a deeply committed and constantly
curious artist
he had so much amazing work still left
to create
i am endlessly grateful for our
friendship rest in power king
well everyone it's that time of year
again film festivals are underway and to
celebrate fandango now has created a
list of film festival favorites
some of which you may be surprised
debuted at a film festival
and today to guide us through how
festivals have changed over the last
decade is awards editor at variety
clayton davis clayton what film has
surprised you that debuted at a festival
you know i've been covering festivals
for the last 10
12 years and i'll never forget
the day that her debuted at the new york
film festival
and it was a movie by spike jones sorry
joaquin phoenix
had no idea that it was going to be as
brilliant as it was
and then even when it was over saying to
one of my colleagues right next to me
and i followed the academy awards very
closely saying to
him there's no way oscar will ever go
for this this is way too
high brow they're not that cool yet and
then
watching that evolve over an award
season getting
nominated for like six oscars winning
original screenplay
hands down one of the best things i've
ever seen i don't know
the audience just took it in it was
great to watch did you cry
uh i did not i did cry though
uh during moonlight when moonlight
debuted and that was like a whole
other can of worms because that was like
tied to obviously the film itself and
what i was watching
but just also seeing black cinema evolve
on screen
in front of me you know that didn't
involve slavery
you know only you know and then to see
people
be touched by it watch it go through
that season
and then take down a behemoth like la la
land
at the end of the day with just icing on
the cake and la land's very good
but moonlight was one of those special
things that you don't
get to see very often what what a moment
in general that whole situation was
um but yeah i'm always gonna be mad
about the oscar moment though because it
always it always gets diluted because of
the whole mix-up
and that's what people remember and i
would have loved
just to see it actually unravel in the
way that
it would have been so i honestly
remember both movies because of that
but yeah it did deserve its its own
moment
for sure for sure which titles playing
this year at a festival
are you looking forward to i'm really
excited for a nomad land
from chloe zao uh she did this very
small indie movie a few years ago called
the writer many probably have not heard
of it nor seen it
if you do have the moment i recommend
you check it out
but this is her follow-up film uh stars
francis mcdormand and david stratharin
i'm so excited about it i think it's
going to be
something very special and it just also
makes her a double threat this year
because she's also directing the
eternals uh from marvel studios that's
dropping
right before the eligibility period is
over for the academy awards
so she may have the most critically
acclaimed film of the year and
possibly the highest grossing film of
the calendar year so
i'm i'm i'm so ready for a close-up yeah
get in there now
get like start standing especially
uh parasite one best picture asian
cinema is here man
it's making its impact and you know
asian filmmakers are
are coming in and assessing you know
their their abilities in the industry
and it's it's beautiful to see i'm
really excited bring it on
bring it on there's some really great
stuff out there but speaking of
like just how things have changed how
has the circuit
like the festival circuit changed in
general i think uh what studios have
really
been laser focused on is to avoid
uh overexposure you know some some
movies will stop at every single fall
festival
along the way however we've seen uh some
films
don't go to enough festivals and i think
there's also a fear from studios of
peaking too early
you know uh you know when you follow the
season as you go into the summer time
you don't want to be deemed the one to
beat before anyone's even seen your
movie
because you could still be very good but
not live up to that masterpiece
expectation
and then it's hard to navigate that what
about like misconceptions what are some
common misconceptions about film
festivals
uh one that it's only for the hoity
toity
like independent small little film thing
that's not the case joker went to venice
last year
and walking phoenix's best actor run
started there
so it's not just for the independent
films you can take a blockbuster there
make a billion dollars and then get be
the most nominated film
of the year with 11 academy awards so
that there's that and then also i think
there's a misconception about if you
don't go to a festival
that means the studio doesn't believe in
you or something's wrong with your movie
perfect example of that was the
follow-up to moonlight was barry jenkins
and beale street could talk
it skipped a lot of the early stuff and
another example would be like martin
scorsese silence didn't go to any
festivals because he wasn't finished yet
sometimes they're going until the last
possible second
yeah and it seems like in a way you know
as someone who appreciates film it's
it's it's a much more raw experience in
in that way it seems like and there's
there's nothing like endless and
festival crowds or
or festival auras are real like we
always hear every time
you know this when we got a 10-minute
standing ovation i can and like
listen there's a lot that can happen
when you have the director
in the room with you and all the actors
are there
and then everyone gets really happy and
clap you know so don't read into
that the the reaction of a of a festival
crowd
i i always say take that with a great
assault i respect you saying that out
loud i've never heard anyone say that
and i and i'm always like i've been
there before
i've been to what i've been like i do
think i do think it's interesting though
flip side of that it's going to make me
kind of i'm going to be a hypocrite in
this way
when you hear there's booze at a
festival and the director's there and
the actors are there
i think you should read into that i
think that means something
yeah okay that's bad that they don't
care
yeah i remember i even showed my card uh
talking to the producer
one of the producers for the two popes
which i love uh but he also
produced uh it chapter two and we were
talking and i was like listen i always
hate
and i have to meet with the talent after
the movies i always feel like i have to
walk on egg shows in case i didn't like
the movie
so i was like but don't worry i like two
popes who were fine and he was like oh i
had another movie this year i was like
oh which one he was like in chapter two
it was like oh
and then he was like what'd you think
and i was like um i know what you just
said so tell me the truth i was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
a little discussion about it you gotta
do the thing where you
you pick like one thing they're just
like i really like the lighting you know
i was like jessica chastain is so
talented
and i can't believe you made the old
spice guy
a star clayton davis
thank you so much for coming on the show
where can people find you
uh you can follow me twitter instagram
facebook uh
you know i'm there uh my uh at handle is
as award circuit which is my former site
that i founded
uh but now i'm at variety so you can uh
look for myself there as of september
first
oh awesome i guess the last question is
who's going to win
the academy awards this year i have i
have no mad land
but again i haven't seen it yet but this
is what oscar predictor does we predict
stuff before we even see the movie
no mad land's going to be it's going to
be uh i have my eye on that but watch
out for mank
watch out for trial of chicago 7.
there's so many great movies coming
coming this year man that's so good to
hear it really is good
movies are still alive don't don't let
kovid fool you there's still great
movies out there
it's gonna be weird ways to watch them
but they exist
support especially independent cinema oh
my god judas and the black messiah is
coming we got regina king directed the
movie i'm so excited about this year
it's gonna be baller
like take it all in awesome
cool thanks man
new and finally in theaters this weekend
tenet
there are people in the future who need
us
you get something not gonna like
time isn't the problem getting out alive
that's the problem the christopher nolan
written and directed film is open in
select theaters right now and will be
expanding to even more theaters on
thursday
armed with only one word tenant and
fighting for the survival of the entire
world
the protagonist journeys through a
twilight world of international
espionage
on a mission that will unfold in
something beyond real time
the film stars john david washington
robert pattinson and elizabeth debicki
but if you're looking for something to
watch at home this weekend why not check
out
the owners tell me what's going on just
a few
minutes more and then a lovely
long sleep a group of friends think
they've found the perfect easy score
an empty house with a safe full of cash
but when the elderly couple that lives
there
comes home early the tables are suddenly
turned
as a deadly game of cat and mouse ensues
the would-be thieves are left to fight
to save themselves
from a nightmare they could never have
imagined the home invasion thriller
stars maisie williams
rita tushingham and sylvester mccoy all
right that's it for today but check out
that full list of film festival
favorites in the link below and leave us
a comment and let us know if you'll be
checking out tenant i'm kale and i'll
see you next time
you